I want to pull up this tweet from the
red-headed libertarian who says this
might be my finest prediction in one
image the red-headed libertarian said we
are totally going to find out in
mid-november that no one's getting their
loans forgiven LMAO Biden you Playa and
then we have November 10th 808 PM
breaking federal judge rules Biden's
plan to cancel hundreds of billions of
dollars of student loan debt is
unconstitutional and must be vacated and
all of these people they ran these
videos where it was like cash in your
pocket cashing and it's like it's like
someone taking cash and it was like vote
for Biden all these young people this is
the problem with low information voters
make the voting age 50. I don't care
these young people are like hey did you
hear Biden's gonna give me money oh vote
for him and then they do why aren't I
getting my money now because he lied to
you dude he has a problem we're we're
old people we've all been through this
young people they haven't experienced it
so fool me once shame on you fool me
twice shame on me these young people
were just fooled for the first time I
don't blame them they were trusting
Americans who said this guy says he's
going to help me out and sure enough
they got played now I just hope each and
every one of you Democrats young people
who thought Joe Biden was going to give
you cash and help you out realizes he
lied to you I ain't telling you to vote
Republican but just remember how they
lied to you because it will happen again
no 100 there was never a plan to do that
there was never a plan like you remember
when Joe Biden said uh Bill back better
is going to pay for itself
I mean that was a fun idea that was a
fun idea or the inflation reduction act
that has 80 000 IRS agents that Bill
Gates pretty much wrote 87 000. it's
gonna go after the little person like
that only has a little bit in their
account well I mean you remember what
the media did with Donald Trump saying
that Mexico was going to pay to build a
wall and then Joe Biden comes along with
a bill back better I like I remember it
which again his inflation plan is
nothing but a you know climate change
protection policy right there I remember
when they came out with the green New
Deal and AOC was just Champion for that
thing it looked like a fifth grader
wrote something in crayon right nobody
believed that there would be a 91
trillion dollar infrastructure rebuild
nobody believed that because what's a
trillion nobody knows what a trillion is
they say trillion and we just White
Noise it right and because nobody
understands what that number means we
just throw that around like it's no big
deal but by God I mean between modern
monetary Theory the ESG scores uh
they're believing that deficit and debts
are good things uh a cashless Society
World economic Forum all this stuff
going on and now you see what's going on
I mean Joe Biden actually flipped the
script the other day by saying the quiet
stuff out loud and saying oh we're going
to get rid of all these coal plants
we're going to get rid of all this stuff
we're gonna We're not gonna have that
we're gonna shut them all down we're
gonna have win we're gonna have solar
they're telling us what they're doing
they don't care you know they don't care
if you're you know they've got what was
their deal we're gonna we're gonna get
you spend 500 000 to winterize your home
and we'll give you a 300 tax credit this
is the end of the year that's the
inflation plan this is what you have you
have college students or broke and in
debt they don't own property they own
nothing and they're unhappy and so then
you have working Americans who either
own a home through loans inheritance or
maybe have a vehicle or maybe maybe
you're still running but have family and
have responsibilities
those people are paying attention to why
their lives are being destroyed why is
my gas so expensive why can't I find
work why are the specialty jobs going
away they get mad at Democrats young
college students who are getting free
money they're using loan money to live
off of they don't have to work for
anything they just don't want to pay
loans the Democrats just offered them
the entire world
that's it I knew a guy he had student
loans and what did he do just party
that's that's that's it I think but this
was this was normal in Chicago CJ tons
of tons of people they get student loans
and they go party I mean they use it for
school and then they go party on the
weekends and I'm like you're doing no
work
you're going to school and now you want
me to pay your bills I'm I'm sorry that
just doesn't make sense but it's kind of
crazy that Millennials I think they were
only like two points behind we were I'm
a millennial two points behind voting
um
Republicans versus Democrat they because
they're having babies now they're
growing up they have jobs and so where
they came out for like Obama but I in
the midterms I'm pretty sure they were
almost close to even I mean we always
make fun of Millennials but they were
voting Republican more this time around
well they have responsibility yeah yeah
their payments there's mortgages we grew
up yeah that's the thing so when I was
when I was working in Hollywood and and
out there you know my agent my manager
out there my manager had a guy that
worked for him and and uh he's a black
guy he worked on he'd worked on several
several Studio lots and stuff and and
we'd go to dinner and and Fred he was he
would say man I'm a Democrat because I
grew up a Democrat I grew up my family
was Democrats I've never known anything
different and my manager Arthur he would
say it's because you haven't made any
money yet yep you haven't made any money
yet when you make a little money you'll
you'll change and this was a guy in
Hollywood this was a manager who's been
you know 40 years in the television
industry out there who where if you're
you're anathema I mean you're a curse
you're ostracized you're outside of the
gate man you were shunned if you come
out as a as a conservative who's saying
well yeah but you're not concerned
because you're not having any money yet
it's a kind of one of those Open Seasons
wasn't the Biden Administration meeting
with the influencers on tick tock to get
all those Jen's ears or did I dream that
well I mean we had the Jonas brother he
had everybody from the Jonas Brothers to
the the Dylan Mulvaney at the White
House so obviously he's doing that yes
yes yeah so
I'll tell you we're in a situation where
this is a controlled fault that this is
not even control they're trying to
control the downward spiral they're
crashing the plane we know the plane is
crashing we know that they want this
economy in shambles we want everything
done it it just done away with it things
that we've held valuable in traditional
in America and uh they don't care they
know that they can do this pin all the
blame on a Joe Biden who he ain't got
along like I said his toes are on the
precipice so they can do that well they
don't care he doesn't have to campaign
he can lick the windows in Delaware it
doesn't matter what he's doing it
doesn't matter what he's doing it
doesn't matter what he says the other
day they just asked him they said what
are you going to do to improve over
what's happened in the last two years he
said nothing well and I think they know
that it creates chaos and Chaos creates
fear and then they know that they can
control you once fear sets in and then
you're going to always vote for him so
we saw that the last two years yes
that's all they got is fear you know
well Republicans are going to need more
than whatever it is they're offering to
because they The Establishment doesn't
want to The Establishment wants to stay
the unit party they want to they want to
keep that deal but that Deal's done Maga
came and it's not so much about Trump
anymore I mean you got DeSantis now and
if these if the if the establishment the
leadership doesn't realize they're you
know what I'll put it this way I think
they're willing to sacrifice victory for
as long as it takes they will just say
we don't care they're the same thing as
the Democrats so they'll just keep
sitting back and letting you know actual
Americans suffer hoping that eventually
Maga stops it's not going to I think the
one thing that needs to happen right now
for all the Republicans going in is just
absolutely reject McConnell and McCarthy
100 it's gone nope not gonna happen
under no circumstances sorry you tell
them you know for all these new members
of Congress you can be like there is
nothing on God's green earth that will
make me support you as Speaker you
better pick somebody else anyone else
but there but you know the problem is
we've had people come in here who are
just like well yeah have to I'm like no
you don't you can you can say have fun
have fun bring Pelosi back I guess see
that's the thing I've called it the good
old boys club forever you know you've
been a member of this country club for
30 years now it's time for you to be the
chairman of the board it's your turn
strong language screw that I mean we've
got to screw that that's that's I mean
put Marjorie Taylor green makers
absolutely let's have at it let's have a
free-for-all yeah no no hands down uh
if that I I think the challenge though
as I said is they would give up they
would say okay then we'll sabotage it if
you try to go against us the
establishment so where do you go from
there I guess
keep running
keep
new people and just wait I think before
we we fix social media this problem is
going to keep happening I think social
media has far of a bigger impact on
people's perceptions and realities than
we could even realize and I think a lot
of them are being manipulated by the DHS
by the FBI by the doj that have their
hands in big Tech social media and and
are deciding who has a voice and who
hasn't and I truly do think that with
this midterm that this big Tech social
media censorship had far more of an
impact than a lot of people realize I
think what we saw also in 2020 with Mark
Zuckerberg spending 419 million dollars
to help people vote an effort that
predominantly helped the Democrats I I
think that also had a big impact also
also in Florida where Rhonda santis made
sure that he passed the law Banning what
he called Zucker bucks that couldn't be
used in his state so I think that also
played a role in Florida having such a
significant Victory here what Ron
DeSantis seeing hey this big Tech social
media guy is trying to influence this by
putting his money in there let's make
sure his money doesn't go to Florida and
I think this is one reason why Ron
DeSantis had such a victory because Mark
Zuckerberg wasn't able to have his own
light needs to win well and I think also
that's why you have Biden saying we need
to investigate Elon Musk now because
they don't want that Free Speech
platform these people are evil and I'll
tell you why they this woman gets up and
she says should we be investigating Elon
Musk in the Saudi billionaire investor
and Biden's like we should be looking
into it that investor was an original
investor he already had a billion plus
in Twitter before Elon stepped in but
now they may ignore it and and a lot of
people not just Maga people were saying
hey shouldn't we take a look at this
because this isn't influencing our
politics now that Elon stepson all of a
sudden they're coming I'm going oh what
a problem we have here these people are
evil man let's let's look at a couple of
things in the last two years under the
quote-unquote pandemic which by the way
if we ever have a real pandemic I'm dead
because I'm not getting vaxxed or
anything else I'm not doing any of that
stuff I mean no experimental stuff for
me but the thing is in fact I'm thinking
about getting my vasectomy reversed
because this stuff is going to be like
the new crypto
this is new Bitcoin uh right here and so
here's my thing we look at all the
tyrannies we came under the stuff that
was revealed America is held together by
a three-quarter Trend okay the media
education and the courts we've lost the
media we've lost education we've barely
holding on to the courts right barely at
least we saw with the overturning of Roe
v Wade that the courts came out in favor
of the constitution in that case put the
rights back into the in favor of the
states making their own decisions but
look at all the tyrannies that are there
and we got to be real careful because
you've got medical tyranny we saw that
you got corporate here and you got big
Tech tyranny that we're discussing
you've got big government which you even
big government that's bureaucratic
tyranny because we're being ruled not by
elected representatives but by 2.5
million unelected bureaucrats in
Washington DC who are getting paid to
rule over us uh you got educational
tyranny you got the mainstream media
tyranny and at some point in time I'm
trying to figure out when we start
spilling tea into the harbor right
because this is this is [ __ ] and
we're looking at all this stuff and
there's no end in sight for it thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time